[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you watch the super bowl
if you listened to the super bowl you
heard the voice of our
next announcer our next voice the
renowned pa announcer
alan roach the voice of 12 super bowls
six olympics
uh a world cup uh ea sports madden
with the avalanche the vikings a variety
of things and uh alan kind enough to
join us
on the program alan good morning how are
the pipes today
huh hi dan good morning pleasure to be
on the show
uh feels like you may have had some
whiskey and some cigarettes this morning
to improve that voice
trying to out-voice me today alan did
you yeah well i've been up 90 minutes so
of course
okay can you not have that voice
[Laughter]
like when you're around the house with
the family or your wife
let's say you call up and order a pizza
how does how does alan roach order a
pizza
i would like uh sausage and mushroom
please
how often are you recognized by just
your voice
always because i'm never recognized by
the mug
it's it's truly amazing how like even
with a mask on now
yeah go to the grocery store and just
the question
uh paper plastic hey are you the
announcer guys
how do you grow up to be a public
address announcer
yeah well that's kind of a long story
that we don't have time for but
uh just fell into it i mean the the very
first job i got was with the colorado
springs sky
socks when they were uh the cleveland
indians affiliate i was doing radio in
colorado springs
happened to go to a sky sox game one
night with a friend
uh went up in the press box because he'd
known the gm
uh just showed me around i saw the guy
over in the corner doing pa i said hey
if he's ever uh
steve ever goes on vacation needs a
break whatever i'd like to try that
gm so have you ever done it no but i
think i could do that
so well actually he's going to be gone
in like two weeks gonna miss a weekend
would you like to do three games
sure i did the three games and they came
to me after those and said
if you want the job it's yours best
moment you've ever had
as a pa announcer is what oh man
that's that's the best part of my job is
there's way too many to count
i mean uh david tyree catching the
football on his helmet
uh joe sakic passing the stanley cup to
ray bork
joe sakic and the canadians winning the
gold medal in salt lake city olympics
for the first time in however many years
it had been back then
um the six shootout goals by tj oshie
sitting in a uh arena in russia with 16
000
russian fans all ready to kill me after
the game was over
um yeah memories our memories are so
many that's that's i've been blessed
what's your worst pa announcing moment
ah i i've really only made one mistake
it was the day well okay i made a few
it was the day that uh
mark maguire got traded from
oakland to st louis okay tony larussa
was already in st
louis mark maguire got traded at like
six o'clock in the evening
on the night that the rockies were
playing and i was announcing the rockies
and we were playing the cubs that day
so in the press box where i sat there's
50 writers
and for a half hour all anyone could
talk about was mark mcguire got traded
mark maguire got traded mark maguire got
traded
so we get around to whatever reigning it
is and the first baseman from the
chicago cubs walks up to the plate
and i open the microphone and i say now
batting
number 17 which should have been mark
grace
and i said mark mcguire
and grace turned around at the plate and
stared at me
and he grounded out to shortstop i
talked to him i don't know
three or four years after that when he
was broadcasting with
arizona and i said hey i'm i'm the
announcer alan roach do you remember
when mark yes i remember that i met you
all the way to first place
he's alan roach the renowned pa
announcer joining us uh
on the program yeah i was wondering when
uh well let me let me play
i only did it once i did public address
announcing once now i've handed out the
super bowl trophy
uh four times so then you get the big
um you know anthem the you know the
stadium feel to it
and you always got to be worried about
the the feedback there or uh you know it
the echo
but this is what i did at spring
training in scottsdale arizona i think
back in 2003 2004
i want you to tell me and be honest what
you think of my pa announcing
skills the left fielder and reigning
national league mvp
barry bonds
bonds the left fielder
batting forth number 25 a man who
homered in his lasted bat
for me let's all rise and welcome
barry bonds
all right what do you think alan i think
you should have made it more about you
[Laughter]
well he did homer for me he homered
twice
and i was doing my radio show and i
asked the giants
so simultaneously when's the last time
you did a radio show and then did public
address announcing alan
i did that for 20 years i used to leave
my radio show early
in downtown denver i'd record the last
hour of my show
and then go over to the ballpark and
announce the rockies games i did that
every year for 15 years yeah but i was
doing it
my radio show and then i went to the
booth next door
holding the microphone for my radio show
and the microphone for the pa
for scottsdale you know arizona and
there had to be
hundreds of people there alan to listen
to what i had to say
and bonds turns around when i say and
now batting
a man who homered for me and his last
and bonds turns around like
who the hell is this but that's the only
time i've done
public address announcing do you want to
introduce us
could you do the starting five for the
dan patrick show
sure sure i can give that a shot okay
all right
well let's see let's start with the
front row
this former mailman checks in at six
foot
183 pounds he chose
to leave west virginia university
yeah right seton oh
[Applause]
connor and you know the fact that alan
has this information
all on his own that's that's the
professional okay all right continue
this snarky producer still lives in the
distant past with the 85 bears
he spent so many years at southern
illinois he should have a doctorate
he doesn't he barely graduated
you probably hate him because most
everyone does
he's paul nailed it
yeah true you have truth in there yeah
right right here
jv power forward at dartmouth he's a
fine
writer but he's known much more for
breaking his glasses on national tv say
hello
to andrew
[Applause]
this pervy booker likes chain
restaurants
chunky turtleneck oatmeal sweaters and
avoiding doing any manly chores or tasks
he's todd for it
how does he know so much about todd
that's amazing fantastic reason
that is amazing that is amazing
this talking hairdo values his hair
more than most of his relatives he told
me so
he's a fan of warm takes and good
tequila
not in that order he's dan
patrick wow all right
yeah look you crushed it out you you
absolutely you you crushed it any great
memorabilia
i know that's what's amazing any
memorabilia
that you anything cool that you've
collected through the years with all
these uh events you've done
oh yeah uh just super bowl stuff i mean
one of the coolest things is uh i have
one of the one of the pictures back here
but
the nfl gives me a super bowl watch
every year as
uh a thank you for for doing the games
so i have uh
13 watches from the super bowls that
i've done
uh basic basically everything that was
given out in the first 14 years of the
colorado rockies to the first
5 000 fans
4 999 fans because i got one
but alan is is this in lieu of payment
you do the super bowl
public address announcing and you get a
watch
well i get a few bucks too and to watch
okay
yeah uh the best halftime show
that you've introduced probably prince
yeah and prince was awesome yeah
and then after that for me it was just
the first one
uh in detroit was i
probably probably one of the greatest
sentences i've ever said on a microphone
ladies and gentlemen the rolling stones
uh are you booked for next year in los
angeles
let's hope so i think i have the job
until i screw it up
yeah cause i i don't know if paulie
should i try to
bigfoot now how about you could be the
understudy you're going to be in l.a
anyway if alan has a rough night out we
could take him out on the town and bang
him up
dan i think i i think i announced you
awarding the
vince lombardi trophy was it in detroit
um
let's see where was i i know i was in
tampa
for the steelers okay in arizona yeah
i'm sure you did introduce me
so we have worked together alan
absolutely
no i know i i appreciate that hey uh
thank you for being a great sport
and uh we we'd love to have you back on
again we appreciate it
hey uh it's my pleasure what a what a
huge show for me to be a part of
congrats on all your success dan i'm a
big fan
thank you alan that's alan roach the
renowned pa announcer voice of 12 super
bowls six olympics
but who's counting